the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so let's move on to our second
chapter and hopefully in this chapter
you will feel a little better if you
felt like it was going a bit fast in the
first chapter and the main reason why I
actually went fast especially in terms
of you know conference interval some of
you came and asked me what do you mean
by this is a confidence interval
what does it mean that it's not
happening in there with probability 95%
etc I just went really fast so that you
could see why I didn't want to give you
a first week doing you know probability
only and without understanding what the
contact the statistical context for it
was right so hopefully all these things
that we've done in terms of probability
you actually know why we've been doing
them and so we're basically going to go
back to what we're doing maybe start
with some statistical setup but the goal
of this lecture is really going to go
back again to what we've seen from a
purely statistical perspective all right
so the first thing we're gonna do is
explain why we're doing statistical
modeling right so in practice if I if
you have data if you observe a bunch of
points and here I gave you some some
some numbers for example so here's a
partial data set with the number of
siblings including self that were
collected from college students a few
years back right so I had was teaching a
class like yours and actually asked
students to go and fill out some Google
Form and tell me a bunch of things and
one of the questions was including
yourself how many siblings do you have
and so they gave me this list of numbers
right and and there's many ways I can
think of this list of numbers right I
could think of it as being just a
discrete distribution on the set of
numbers between one I mean I know
there's not gonna be an answer which is
less than one unless about someone
doesn't understand the question but all
the answers I should get are
positive integers 1 2 3 etc and you know
there probably isn't a prevail but I
don't know it on the top of my head so
maybe I should say 100 maybe I should
say 15 depends right and so I think the
largest number I got for this was 6
alright so here you can see you have
pretty standard families you know lots
of ones twos and threes ok so the way
what statistical modeling is doing is to
try to compress this information that I
could actually describe in a very naive
way so let's start with the basic usual
statistical setup right so I will start
many of the boards that look like X 1 X
and random variables and what I'm gonna
assume as we said typically is that
those guys are iie and they have some
distribution all right so they all share
the same distribution and the fact that
there are ID is so that I can actually
do statistics statistics means you know
looking at the global averaging thing so
that I can actually get a sense of what
the global behavior is for the
population right if I start assuming
that those things are not identically
distributed they all live on their own
right that my sequence of number is your
number of siblings the shoe size of this
person the depth of the Charles River
and I start measuring a bunch of stuff
there's nothing I'm gonna actually get
together I need to have something that's
cohesive and so here I collected some
data that was cohesive and so the goal
here the first thing is to say what is
the distribution that I actually have
here right so I could actually be very
general I could just say it's some
distribution P and let's say those are
their random variables not random
vectors where they could collect entire
vector it's about let's say those are
just random variables and so now I can
start making assumptions on this
distribution P right what can I say
about a distribution well maybe if those
numbers are continuous for example I
could assume they have a density right a
probability density function that's
already an assumption maybe I could
start to assume that their probability
density function is
that's another assumption maybe I could
actually assume that it's piecewise
constant that's even better right and
those things make my life simpler and
simpler because what I do by making the
second successive assumptions is
reducing the degrees of freedom of the
space in which I'm actually searching
the distribution and so what we actually
want is to have something which is small
enough so we can actually have some
averaging going on but we also want
something which is big enough that it
can actually express it has chances of
actually containing the tribution that
makes sense for us so let's start with
the simplest possible example which is
when the x i's belong to 0 1 and as I
said here we don't have a choice the
distribution of those guys has to be
Burnley and since there III they all
share the same key think of they're just
vernal ep ok and so all I would have to
figure out in this case is T and you
know this is the simplest case and I'm
surprisingly it has the simplest answer
right we will come back to this example
when we study maximum likelihood
estimators or method of moments
estimators by the method of moments but
at the end of the day the things that we
did the things that we will do are
always the naive is Commuter you would
come up with is what is the proportion
of 1 and this will be in pretty much all
respects the best estimator you can
think of all right so then we're gonna
try to assesses performance and we saw
how to do that in the first chapter as
well so this problem here somehow it's
completely understood we'll come back to
it but there's nothing fancy that is
gonna happen but now I could have some
more complicated things right so for
example in in the example of the
students now my X eyes belong to the
sequence of integers 1 2 3 etc okay
which is also denoted by n maybe without
zero if you want to put zero in n right
so the positive integers
or I could actually just maybe put some
prior knowledge about how humans have
time to have families but you know maybe
some some people thoughts of their
college mates as being their brothers
and sisters and one student would
actually put you know four hundred and
sixty-five siblings because you know
we're all good friends and or maybe they
actually think that all their Facebook
contacts are actually their siblings and
so you know you never know what's gonna
happen so you maybe you want to account
for this but maybe you know that people
are reasonable and they will actually
give you something like this now
intuitively maybe you would say well why
would you bother doing this if you're
not really sure about the twenty but I
think that probably all of you
intuitively yes that this is probably a
good idea to start putting this kind of
assumptions rather than allowing for any
number in the first place because this
eventually will be injected into the
precision of our estimator if I don't if
I allow anything it's gonna be more
complicated for me to get an accurate
estimator if I know that the numbers are
either 1 or 2 then I'm actually gonna be
slightly more accurate as well all right
because I know that see for example
somebody put the 5 I can remove it and
it's not gonna actually throw up with my
estimator all right so
now let's say we actually agree that we
have numbers and here I put seven
numbers okay so I just said well now the
numbers let's assume that the numbers
I'm gonna get are gonna be one all the
way to say this number that I denote by
larger than or equal to seven which is a
placeholder for any number larger than
seven okay because I know maybe I don't
want to distinguish between people have
nine or 25cm
okay and so now this is a distribution
on seven possible values a discrete
distribution then you know from you know
your probability class that the way you
describe the distribution is using the
probability mass function okay or PMF
okay so that's how we describe a
discrete distribution and the PMF is a
just a list of numbers right so as I
wrote here you have a list of numbers
and here you wrote the possible value
that the your random variable can take
and here you write the probability that
your random variable takes this value
okay so the possible values being one
two three all the way to larger than or
equal to seven and then I'm trying to
estimate those numbers right if I give
you those numbers at least up to this
you know compression of all numbers
lower than or equal to seven you have a
full description of your distribution
and that is the ultimate goal of
statistics all right you're the ultimate
goal of statistics is to say what
distribution your data came from because
that's basically the best you're gonna
be able to do now admittedly if I
started looking at the fraction of ones
and the fraction of tubes and the
fraction of threes etc I would actually
eventually get those numbers I just like
looking at the fraction of ones gave me
a good estimate for P in the Bernoulli
case it would do the same in this case
right it's a pretty intuitive idea to
the law of large numbers everybody
agrees with that if I look at the
proportion of once the proportion of to
the proportion of fries that should
actually give me some
gets closer and closer as my sample size
increasing increases to what I want but
the problem is if my sample size is not
huge here I have seven numbers to
estimate and if I have you know twenty
observations the ratio is not really in
my favor right I mean you know 20
observations to assume it seven
parameters some of them are gonna be
pretty off typically the ones with the
large values but if I have only twenty
students look at the list of numbers I
don't know how many numbers I have but
it probably is close to 20 maybe 15 or
something and so if you look at this
list no nobody's actually happy nobody
has four or more siblings in this room
right there's no such person so that
means that eventually with from this
dataset my estimates so those numbers I
denote by say p1 p2 p3 etc those
estimates p4 hats would be equal to what
from this data
zero right and p5 hat to be equal to
zero and p6 hat would be equal to zero
and peel order than or equal to seven
equal to zero that would be my estimates
from this data set so maybe this is that
maybe I want to actually pull some
information from the people who have
less siblings to try to make a guess
which is probably slightly better for
the larger values right it's pretty
clear that in average there's more than
zero the proportion of the population
with of households that have four
children or more is definitely more than
zero all right so it means that my data
set is not representative and what I'm
gonna try to do is to find a model that
try to use the data they have for the
smaller values that I can observe and
just [ __ ] up to the other ones and
so what we can do is to just reduce
those parameters into something that's
you know understood and this is part of
the modeling that I talked about in the
first place now how do you since it
succinctly describe a number of
something well one thing that you do is
the question on distribution right
why do puesto I mean there's many
reasons right I mean again that's part
of statistical modeling but once you
know that you have number of something
that can be modeled by a person why not
try a person right you could just fit a
place so when the person is something
that looks like this and I guess you've
all all sinned it but if X follows a
Poisson distribution with parameter
lambda then the probability that X is
equal to little X is equal to lambda to
the X over factorial X e to the minus
lambda
okay
and if you did the the the first the
sheet that I gave you on the first day
you can check that those numbers so this
is of course 4x equals 0 1 etc right so
X is in natural integers and if you sum
from x equals 0 to infinity this thing
you get e to the lambda and so they
cancel and you have a sum which is equal
to 1 so it's indeed a PMF but what's key
about this PMF is that it never takes
value 0 but this thing is always trickly
positive so whatever value of lambda I
find from this data will give me
something that's certainly more
interesting than just putting the value
0 but more importantly rather than
having to estimate 7 parameters and as a
consequence to actually have to estimate
1 2 3 4 of them equal to 0
I have only one parameter to estimate
which is London the problem with doing
this is that now lambda may not be just
something as simple as computing the
average number right in this case but in
many instances it's actually not clear
that this parameterization with lambda
that I chose is good I'm gonna be able
to estimate Linda just by computing the
average number by 2 it will be the case
but if it's not you know remember this
example of the exponential we did in the
last lecture we could use the Delta
method and things like that to estimate
it all right so here's a here's the you
know modeling 101 so the purpose of
modeling is to restrict the space of
possible distributions to a subspace
that's actually plausible that's much
simpler for me to estimate right so
we're 8 we went from all distributions
on seven parameters which is a large
space that's a lot of things to
something which is just one number now
this number is positive okay
any question about the purpose of doing
this okay so we're gonna have to do a
little bit of formalism now and so if we
want to talk right this is just a class
so I'm not gonna want to talk about the
personal model specifically every single
thing I'm gonna want to talk about
generic models and then you're gonna be
able to plug in your favorite word no
question on binomial exponential uniform
all these words that you've seen you're
gonna be able to plug in there but we're
just gonna have some generic notation
some generate terminology for
statistical model all right so here's
the formal definition so I'm gonna go
through it with you
okay so the definition is that of a
statistical model
okay and so sorry that's a statistical
experiment I should say okay so a
statistical experiment is actually just
a pair and that's a set and a family of
distributions P theta where theta ranges
in some set capital theta okay so I hope
you're up to date with your Greek
letters so the small theta it's the
capital theta okay and so this thing now
so each of this guy is a probability
distribution all right so for example
this could be a person with parameter
theta or a Bernoulli
with parameters theta okay we're an
exponential with parameter I don't know
1 over theta squared if you want okay
but they're just indexed by theta but
for each theta this completely describes
the distribution it could be more
complicated this theta should be a pair
could be a pair am you Sigma Square and
that could actually give you some n new
Sigma squared okay so anything where you
can actually rather than actually giving
you a full distribution I can compress
it into a parameter but it could be
worse it could be this guy here right
theta could be P 1p larger than or equal
to 7 and my distribution could just be
something that has PMF P 1p larger than
7
that's another parameter is this one has
seven seven dimensional this one is
two-dimensional and all these guys are
just one dimension okay all these guys
are parameters that clear what's
important here is that once I give you
theta you know exactly all the
probabilities associated to this random
variable you do its distribution
perfectly okay so here so this is the
different is that clear form is there a
question about this distribution about
this definitions right all right so
really the key thing is the statistical
model associated to a statistical
experiment okay so let's just see some
examples it's probably just better
because again with formalism it's never
really clear actually that's the next
slide okay so there's two things we need
to assume I mean there's okay so the
purpose of a statistical model is to
once I estimate the parameter I actually
know exactly what the distribution I
have okay so it means that I could
potentially have several parameters that
give me the same distribution that would
still be fine because I could estimate
one guy or I could estimate the other
guy and I would still recover the
underlying distribution of my data the
problem is that this creates really
annoying theoretical problems like
things don't work the algorithms won't
work the guarantees won't work and so
what do we typically assume is that the
model is so-called well specified all
right sorry that's not well specified
I'll I'm jumping ahead of myself
okay well specified means that your data
the distribution of your data is
actually one of those guys okay so some
vocabulary
so well-specified means that for my
observations X there exists a theta in
capital theta such that X follows p sub
theta should put a double vote okay so
that's what well-specified means okay so
that means that the distribution of your
actual data is just one of those guys
this is a bit strong of an assumption
all right it's strong in the sense that
you know I don't know if you've heard of
this a sentence which I don't know I can
tell you who it's attributed to but that
probably means that this person did not
come up with it but it said that all
models are wrong but some of them are
useful all right so all models are wrong
means that maybe it's not true that this
was some distribution that I assumed for
the number of siblings for college
students
maybe that stuff perfectly correct maybe
there's a spike at three right
maybe there's a spike get one because
you know maybe those are slightly more
educated families they have less
children maybe this is actually not
exactly perfect but it's probably good
enough for our purposes and when we make
this assumption we're actually assuming
that the data really comes from a
platform model there is a lot of
research that goes on about misspecified
models and that tells you how well
you're doing in the model that's the
closest to the actual distribution so
that's pretty much it
yeah X is so right so by data so it's
always the way I Jenner note one of the
generic observations right so my
observations are X 1 X n and they're iid
with distribution P always so X is just
one of those guys I don't want to write
X 5 4 X 4 it's just one their ID so they
all have the same distribution so ok
no no they're all iid so they all have
the same P theta they'll have the same P
which means they'll have the same P
theta so I can pick any one of them so I
just removed the index just with your
face okay so when I write X I just mean
think of X 1 right there our idea I can
pick whichever I want I'm not gonna
write the X 1 it's gonna be weird okay
okay so this particular Stata is called
the true parameter sometime - since
we're gonna want some variable theta we
might denoted by theta star but and so
the aim of the statistical experiment is
to estimate theta so that once I
actually plug in theta in the form of my
distribution for example I could plug in
theta here so theta here was actually
lambda so once I estimate this guy would
plug it in and I would know the
probability that my random variable
takes same value right by just putting a
lambda hat in the lambda hat here okay
so my goal is going to be to estimate
this guy so that I can actually compute
those distributions but actually we'll
see for example when we talk about
regression that this parameter actually
has a meaning in many instances and so
just knowing the parameter itself
intuitively or say more let's say more
so than just computing probabilities
will actually tell us something about
the process so for example we're gonna
run linear regression and when we do
linear regression there's gonna be some
coefficients in the linear regression
and the value of this coefficient is
actually telling me what is the
sensitivity of the response that I'm
looking at to this particular input all
right so just doing if this number is
large or this number is slow a small is
actually going to be useful for us to
just look at this guy all right so
there's gonna be some instances where
it's gonna be important sometimes we're
gonna want to know if this parameter is
larger
we're smaller than something or if it's
equal to something or not equal to
something and those things are also
important for example if theta actually
measures the true right so theta is a
true unknown parameter true efficacy of
a drug okay let's say I want to know
what the true efficacy of a drug is and
what I'm we're gonna want to know is you
know maybe it's a score maybe I'm gonna
want to know which potato is lower than
two maybe I want to know if theta is
been the average number of siblings is
this true number larger than true or not
right maybe I'm interested in knowing if
college students come from so I come
from a be from a sociological
perspective I'm interested in knowing if
college students come from household
with more than two children all right so
those can be the questions that I may
asking myself all right I'm gonna want
to know maybe theta is gonna be equal to
one half or not so maybe for drug
efficacy is it completely standard maybe
for elections are that is the proportion
of the population that is going to vote
for this particular candidates equal to
0.5 or is it different from 0.5 okay and
I can think of different things when I'm
talking about the regression I'm going
to want to test if this coefficient is
actually zero or not because if it's
zero it means that the variable that's
in front of it actually goes out and so
those are things were testing actually
having this very specific X no answer is
gonna give me a huge intuition or a huge
understanding of what's going on in the
phenomenon that I observe but actually
since the questions are so precise is
going to be much more I'm gonna be much
better at answering them rather than
giving you an estimate for theta with
some confidence around it all right it's
this sort of the same principle as
trying to reduce right what you're
trying to do as a statistician is to
inject as much knowledge about the
question and about the problem that you
can so that the data has to do a minimal
job and in sports you actually need less
data right so for now on we will always
assume and this is because this is an
intro stats class you will always assume
that theta the sub set of parameters is
a subset of R to the D that means that
theta is a vector with at most a finite
number of coordinates why do I say this
well this is called a traumatic model so
it's called a parametric model or
sometimes parametric statistics actually
we don't really talk about parametric
statistics but we talk a lot about
nonparametric statistics or a
nonparametric model can somebody think
of a model which is nonparametric
for example in the siblings example if I
did not tap the number of siblings to 7
but unless I let this list go to
infinity I would have an infinite number
of parameters to estimate very likely
the last ones would be 0 but still I
would have an infinite number of
parameters to estimate so this would not
be a parametric model if I just let this
list of things to us to be estimated to
be infinite but there's other classes
that are actually infinite and cannot be
represented by vectors for example
function right if I tell you my model P
F is just the distribution of X's the
probability distributions that have
density F right so what I know is that
the density is non-negative in that it
integrates to 1 right that's all I knew
about densities well F is not something
you're gonna be able to describe with a
finite number of values right all
possible functions is a huge set it's
certainly not representable by ten
numbers okay and so non parametric
estimation is typically when you
actually want to parameterize this by a
large class of functions and so for
example histograms is the prime tool of
non parametric estimation because when
you fit a histogram to data you're
trying to estimate the density of your
data but you're not trying to represent
it as a finite number of points even
though that's really I mean effectively
you have to represent it right so you
actually truncate somewhere and just say
those things are not gonna matter all
right
but really the key thing is that this is
nonparametric where you have an infinite
potentially infinite number of
parameters whereas we're gonna only talk
about finite and actually finite in most
most overwhelming majority of cases is
gonna be one all right so theta is gonna
be a subset of our one okay we're gonna
be interested in estimating one
parameter just like the parameter of a
of a parcel or the prouder of an
exponential the parameter birnley but
for example really we're gonna be
interested in estimating mu and Sigma
square for the for the normal okay so
here are some statistical models all
right so I'm gonna go through them with
you so we start right so if I tell you I
observe I'm interested in understanding
the I'm still that shallow and I'm
interested in understanding the
proportion of people who kiss by bending
their head to the right and for that I
collected n observations and I'm
interested in making some inference in
this statistical model my question to
you is what is the statistical model
well if you want to write the
statistical model you're gonna have to
write this e oh sorry I never told you
what he was okay well actually it's just
go to the examples and then you'll know
what he is so I'm I'm I mean you're
gonna have to write to me an e and a P
theta okay
so let's start with the Bernoulli trials
so this e here is called the sample
space and in normal people's world words
it just means the space or the set in
which X and back to your question X is
just a generic observation lips okay and
hopefully this is the smallest you can
think of okay so for example for
Bernoulli trials I'm going to observe a
sequence of zeros and ones so my
experiment is going to be as written on
the board is going to be 1 0 1 and then
the probability distributions are gonna
be well it's just gonna be the Burnley
distributions indexed by P right so
rather than writing P sub P I'm gonna
write it as fertile II P because it's
clear what I mean when I write that
there's everybody happy actually I need
to tell you something more this is a
family of distribution so I need P and
maybe I don't want you have P that takes
value 0 1 right I mean it doesn't make
sense I would probably not look at this
problem if I anticipated that everybody
would get to the right and everybody
which or everybody would keep it alive
so I'm going to assume that P is in 0 1
but does not have 0 in it
okay so that's typical model for
Bernoulli trial okay
okay now the next one what do we have
exponential okay okay so when I have
exponential distributions what is the
support of the exponential distribution
what values can it take zero to infinity
right so what I have is that my first
space is the value that by random
variables can take so it's well actually
I can remove the zero again zero to plus
infinity and then the family of
distributions that I have are
exponential with parameter lambda and
again maybe you've seen me switching
from P 2 lambda 2 theta 2 nu 2 Sigma
square other thing you can do whatever
you want but it's just that it's
customary to have this particular Greek
letters okay and so the parameters of an
exponential are just positive numbers
okay and that's my exponential model
what is the third one can somebody tell
me what so okay okay so puesto is the
Poisson random variable discrete or
continuous
go back to your privilege all right so
the interviewing the opposite of
continuous good job all right so it's
gonna be what value is canif West on
tape I'm all the natural integers right
so zero one two three all the way to
infinity we don't have any control of
this so I'm gonna write this as n
without zero I think in the slightest
and star baby
actually no you can take value 0 I'm
sorry this actually takes value 0 quite
a lot that's tough
typically money made since is actually
the mode so it's N and then I'm gonna
write it as quest song with parameter
well here it's again one does a
parameter and lambda can take any
positive value okay
and that's where you can actually see
that the model that we had for the
siblings right so let me actually just
squeeze in the siblings model here
alright so that was the bad model that I
had in the first place when I actually
tapped this let's say we just kept it at
7 forget about the larger than or equal
to 7 we just assumed it was 7 what was
our sample space
we said seven so it's one two two seven
right those were the possible values
that this thing would take and then what
was my what's my parameter space so it's
gonna be making out you're right but I'm
gonna write it okay so I'm gonna write
it that's something like probability
that X is equal to K is equal to P sub K
okay and that's gonna be four key okay
so that's for all case write for k equal
1 to 7 and here the index is the set of
parameters P 1 to P K and I know a
little more about those guys right I
know they're gonna be non-negative
PJ non-negative and I know that this sum
to 1
okay so maybe writing this you start
seeing why we like to quest so
exponential and short notation because I
actually don't have to write the PMF of
well I mean the personal is really just
this but I call it quits um so I'll have
to rewrite this all the time and so here
I did not use a particular form so I
just have this thing and that's what it
is the set of parameters is the set of
positive numbers that scent of sorry P 1
2 P 7 okay and some 2/7 right and so
this is just a list of numbers that are
non-negative and sum up to one so that's
my parameter space
okay so here's that's my data this whole
thing here this is my capital theta okay
so that's just a set of parameters
that's theta the set the parameters of
Thetas a lot of patience ok and finally
we're gonna end with the star of all and
that's the normal distribution and then
the normal distribution there's you
still have also some flexibility in
terms of persist because then that
naturally the normal distribution is
parametrized by the normal distribution
is parametrized by two parameters right
mean and variance I'm gonna so what
values can a Gaussian random variable
take an entire real line right and the
set of parameters that it's uh it can
take it so this is gonna be n nu Sigma
squared and nu is gonna be positive and
Sigma square is going to sorry nu is
going to be in R and Sigma square is
going to be positive
okay so again here that's the way you're
supposed to write it if you really want
to identify what theta is
well theta formally is the set of Mu
Sigma square such that well in our times
0 infinity right that's just to be
formal but this does the job just what
okay so that's not three that's like
five actually I just want to write
another one let's call it five it and
fight this is just Gaussian with known
variants
and this arises a lot in labs when you
have measurement error when you actually
receive your measurement device this
thing has been tested by the
manufacturer so much that they actually
comes in on the side of the box it says
that the standard deviation of your
measurements is going to be 0.23 okay
and actually why do you do this is
because they can brag about accuracy
right I mean that's how they sell you
this particular device and so you
actually know exactly what Sigma Square
is so once you actually get your data in
the lab you actually only have to
estimate you because Sigma comes as
comes on the label
and so now what is your statistical
model well the numbers you're gonna be
collecting still live in R but now the
models that I have is n Mu Sigma square
but the parameter space is not viewing
our in Sigma positive is just mu in our
and to be a little more emphatic about
this this is enough to describe it right
because if Sigma is the Sigma that was
specified by the manufacturer then this
is the Sigma you want but you can
actually write Sigma is equal to Sigma
square is equal to Sigma square
manufacturer all right you can just fix
it to be this particular value or maybe
you don't want to write an index that's
manufacturer and so you just say well
the Sigma when I write Sigma square what
I mean is the Sigma for every
manufacturer yeah
yes
for a particular measuring device you
know you're in a lab and you have some
measuring device I don't know something
that measures the tensile strength of
something is just gonna measure
something and it will naturally make
errors but it's been tested so much by
the manufacturer that they actually and
calibrated by them they know it's not
gonna be perfect but they knew exactly
what error it's making because they've
actually tried it on thing for which the
exactly knew what the dents offering for
okay
this Oh like place one to play spring
okay
and we can come up with other examples
right so for example here's another one
okay so the names don't really matter
right I mean you know I called it the
siblings model but you won't find the
siblings model in a textbook right so I
wouldn't worry too much but for example
let's say you have something so let's
call it six you have I don't know
truncated that's what I want but let's
say I observe Y which is the indicator
of X larger than say five when x follows
some exponential with parameter lambda
okay this is what I get to observe
I only observe if my waiting time was
more than five minutes because I see
somebody coming out of the Kendall
station being really upset and that's
all I recorded I've been waiting for
more than five minutes and that's all I
get to report okay that happens a lot
these are called sensor data I should
probably not call it truncated but this
should be censored okay
you see a lot of sensor data when you
ask for people how much they make they
say well more than they want to tell you
okay and so you see a lot of sensor data
in survival analysis right you you're
trying to understand how long is
patients are gonna live after some
surgery okay and and maybe you're not
gonna keep people live and you're not
gonna actually have their beam touching
their family everyday and as them is the
guy still alive and so what you can do
is just to ask people maybe five years
after your study and say please come in
and you know you will just have happen
to have some people say well you know
the person is deceased and you will only
be able to know that the person this is
less than five years ago I mean but you
only see what happens after that okay
and so this is this truncated and sensor
data happens
all the time just because you don't have
the availability to do better than that
so so so this could happen here so now
what is my statistical experiment right
so here I should really I should
probably write this like that because
just told you that my observations are
gonna be X so there's some unknown
liable never get to see this why I only
seem to get to see the X what is my
statistical experiment please help me so
is it the realign my state sample space
is it the real line sorry do you know
everybody who does not know what this
means sorry okay so this is any called
an indicator so I read it as it's very
wrote well that would be one with a
double bar you can also write the I if
you prefer if you don't feel like
writing 1min double bars and it's one of
say I'm gonna write it like that one of
a is equal to one if a is true and zero
it's a false okay so that means that if
Y is larger than five distinct goes one
is one and it's why it's not large the
larger than five displays here okay so
that's called indicator
indicator function okay
it's very useful to just turn anything
into a zero money so now that I'm here
what is my sample face you're a 1 what
whatever this thing I did not tell you
was taking value was the thing you
should have I need to tell you that's
taking value 6 or 7 that would be your
sample space ok ok so it takes value 0 1
and then what is the probability here
what should I write here what should you
write without even thinking yeah so
let's assume there's two seconds before
the end of the exam you're gonna write
Bernoulli and that's where you're gonna
start checking if I'm gonna give you
extra time okay so you read Bernal leave
without thinking because it's taking
value zero one so you just write Burling
but you still have to tell me what
possible parameters this thing is taking
right so I'm gonna write it P because I
don't know and then P takes value okay
so sorry I could write it like that
right that would be perfectly valid but
actually no more it's not any P the P is
the probability that some exponential
lambda is the other than five and maybe
I want to have lambda at the parameter
okay so what I need to actually compute
is what is the probability that Y is
larger than five when y is this
exponential lambda which means that what
I need to compute is the integral
between five and infinity
are you ready here lambda e to the minus
lambda X DX right so that's what I need
to compute this yeah so what is the
value of this integral you take
appropriate measures
and so what I'm gonna integrate this guy
those guys are gonna cancel I'm gonna
get zero for infinity I'm gonna get a
fight for this guy and well I know it's
gonna be a positive number so I'm really
gonna bother with the spine
okay so I get e to the minus 5 lambda
and so that means that I can actually
write this like that
now parameterize this thing by lambda
positive okay so what I did here is I
change the parameterization from P 2
lambda why well because maybe if this I
know this is happening maybe I'm
actually interested in reporting lambda
2 MBTA for example right maybe I'm
actually trying to n to estimate 1 over
the 1 over lambda so that I know what
they see
well lambda is actually the intensity of
arrival of my of my person process right
if I have a queston process that's where
how my my trains are coming in and so
I'm interested in lambda so I will
parameterize things by lambda so that
the thing I get this limit you can play
with this right that mean I could
probably try this by 1 over lambda and
put 1 over lambda here if I wanted but
you know your the context of your
problem will tell you exactly how Brown
okay so okay let's do a final one
[Applause]
by the way are you guys okay with you
know quest so exponential Burnley's I
don't know binomial normal all these
things I'm not gonna go back to it but
I'm gonna use them heavily so you know
just spend five minutes on Wikipedia if
I forgot about what those things are
usually use or you must have seen them
in your probability class so that should
not be crazy Ning and again I'm not
expecting you I mean I don't remember
what the density of an exponential is so
it would be pretty intere of me to
actually ask you to remember what it is
given for the Gaussian you're expected
to remember what it is but I want you to
remember that you know if I add five to
a Gaussian that I have a Gaussian with
mean mu plus five if I multiply it by
something right I need you need to know
how to operate those things so
but knowing complicated densities is
definitely not part of the game okay so
let's do a final one I don't know what's
number I have no I'm gonna just do a
uniform that's another one everybody
knows what uniform is uniform right so
I'm gonna have X which my observations
are going to be uniform on the interval
zero theta right so if I want to define
a uniform distribution for a random
variable I have to tell you which
interval which set I wanted to be
uniform on and so here I'm telling you
is the interval 0 of theta and so what
is gonna be my sample space I'm sorry 0
2 theta and then what is my probability
distribution my family of parameters
so well I can write it like this right
uniform theta right and cedar let's say
he's positive can somebody tell me
what's wrong with what I wrote
this makes no sense tell me why yeah
yeah this sub depends on theta and why
is that a problem
there's no theta right now there's the
families of theta which one did you pick
here right there's no this is just
something that's indexed by theta but I
could have very well written it as you
know just not being great for a second I
could have just written this as T right
rather than theta okay that would be the
same thing and then what the hell it's
data there's no such thing as theta we
don't know what the parameter is this
parameter should move with everyone and
so that means that I actually am not
allowed to pick this theta
I'm actually just for the reason that
there's no parameter to put on the left
side there should not be right so you
just said well there's a problem because
the parameter is on the left inside but
there's not even a parameter I'm
describing the family of possible
grounders there's no one then you can
actually plug it in so this should
really be one and I'm gonna go back to
writing this as theta because that's
pretty thin that's clear for everyone I
could not just pick one and put it in
there I just take before I run my
experiment I could potentially get
numbers that are all the way up to one
because I don't know what theta is gonna
be ahead of time now if somebody promise
to me that theta was going to be less
than 0.5 that would be sorry what do I
put one here
I could put theta between zero and one
but if somebody's gonna promise me for
example let's say there's gonna be less
than one then yes like this one zero one
all right back there
okay so now you know how to answer the
question what is the statistical model
and again within the scope of this class
you will not be asked to just come up
with a model right that will just tell
you question would be a probably good
idea here and then you would just have
to trust me that indeed would be a good
idea all right
so what I started talking about about 20
minutes ago so it's definitely ahead of
mine of myself is the notion so that's
what I was talking about well-specified
remember well-specified says that the
true distribution is one of the
distribution in this parametric families
of distribution the true distribution of
my siblings is actually a Poisson with
some parameters and all I need to figure
out this would this parameter is when I
started saying that I said well but then
that could be that there are several
parameters that give me the same
distribution right it could be the case
that Wessel five and twelve seventeen
are exactly the same distributions when
I start putting those numbers in the
formula which I reverse okay so it could
be the case that two different numbers
would give me exactly the same
probabilities and in this case we see
that the model is not identifiable I
mean the parameter is not identifiable I
cannot identify the parameter even if
you actually gave me an infinite amount
of data which means that I could
actually estimate exactly the PMF I
might not be able to go back because
there would be several candidates and I
would not be able to tell you which one
it was in the first one okay so what we
want is that this function theta maps to
P theta is injective and that's really
to be fancy what I really mean is that
if theta is different from theta prime
then P of theta is different from P of
theta prime or if you prefer to think
about the contrapositive of this this is
the same as saying that if P theta gives
me the same distribution as theta prime
then that implies that theta must be
equal to theta prime I do not check
those two things are equivalent right
so that's what this what this means that
so this is we say that the parameter is
identifiable or identified doesn't
really matter in this model okay
and this is something we're gonna want
okay so in all the examples that I gave
you those were those parameters are
completely identified right if I tell
you I mean if those things are in
probability books it means that they
were probably thought through right so
when I take financial lambda I'm really
talking about one specific distribution
and not there's not another one that is
going to give me exactly the same
distribution okay so that was the case
and you can check that but it's a little
annoying so I would probably would not
not do it but rather I'm doing this let
me just give you some examples where it
would not be the case okay and here's an
example if I take X I so now I'm back to
just do using this indicator function
but now for a Gaussian alright so what I
observe is X is the indicator that's why
is what did we say positive okay so this
is the Bernoulli random variable right
and it has some parameter P but P now is
going to depend sir in here what is n
use from this square so the P the
probability that this thing is positive
is actually I don't think it puts a zero
so yeah oh yeah because I haven't okay
so this distribution this P the
probability that it's positive it's just
the probability that some Gaussian is
positive and it will depend on mu and
Sigma right because if I draw a zero and
I draw my Gaussian around mu then the
probability of being of this bernly
being 1 is really the area under the
curve here right and this thing well if
mu is very large it's gonna become very
large
if you it's very small it's gonna become
very small and if Sigma changes it's
also gonna affected that clear to
everyone but we can actually compute
this right so the parameter P that I'm
looking for here as a function of MU and
Sigma is simply the probability that
some Y is non-negative which is the
probability that Y minus mu divided by
Sigma is larger than minus mu divided by
Sigma but the way when you study
probability is that some operation you
were used to making removing the mean
and dividing by the standard deviation
what is the effect of doing that on this
on the Gaussian random variable yeah so
you normalize it right you standardize
it you actually make it a standard
Gaussian you remove the mean it becomes
a mean zero Gaussian and you remove the
variance to for it to become one so when
you have a rare Gaussian remove the mean
and divide by standard deviation it
becomes a standard Gaussian which this
thing has n 0 1 distribution which is
the one you can read the point out of at
the end of the book all right then
that's exactly what we did okay so now
you have the probability that some
standard Gaussian exceeds negative mu
over Sigma which I can write in terms of
the cumulative distribution function
capital Phi
like we did in the first lecture so if I
do this relative distribution function
what is this variability in terms of
five
well that's what your nametag says 1
minus 1 minus mu over Sigma what
happened to find are you think I defined
this for fun 1 minus Phi of mu over
Sigma right right because this is 1
minus the probability it's less than
this and this is exactly the definition
of the cumulative distribution function
so in particular this thing only depends
on mu over Sigma agreed so in particular
if I had 2 mu over 2 Sigma P would
remain unchanged if I have 12 new over
12 Sigma this thing would remain
unchanged which means that P does not
change if I scale mu and Sigma by the
same factor so there's no way just by
observing X even an infinite enough time
so that I can actually get exactly what
P is I'm never going to be able to get
mu and Sigma separately all I'm gonna be
able to get is mu over Sigma so here we
say that mu sigma the parameter nu Sigma
or actually each of them individually
those guys they're not a notifiable
but the parameter mu over Sigma is
identifiable so if I wanted to write a
statistical model in which the parameter
is identifiable
I would write here one Burnley and then
I would write 1 minus 5 over of mu over
Sigma and then it would take two
parameters which are new in R and Sigma
squared positive well that's right Sigma
positive right no this is not
identifiable I cannot write those two
guys as being two things missing
instead what I want to write is 0-1
Berlin 1 - and now my parameter my
parameter is mu over Sigma can somebody
tell me where mu over Sigma lives what
values can this thing take any real
value right ok so now I've done this
definitely out of convenience right
because that was the only thing I was
able to identify the ratio of MU over
Sigma but it's still something that has
some meaning
it's the stead it's the normalize mean
it really tells me what the mean is
compared to the standard deviation
between some models in reality in some
real applications this actually might
have a good meaning from there just
telling me how big the mean is compared
to the standard fluctuations of this
model but I won't be able to get more
than that agreed
all right
so now that I've we've said it for a
metric model let's try to see what our
goals are gonna be okay so now we have a
sample and a statistical model and we
want to estimate the parameter theta and
I could say well you know what they
don't have time for this analysis
collecting data is gonna take me a while
so I'm just done mmm
and I'm gonna see that nu over Sigma is
for not very good right so we need some
measure of performance of a given
parameter we need to be able to evaluate
if you know eyeballing the problem is
worse than actually collecting a large
amount of theta we need to know if even
if I come up with an estimator that
actually sort of uses the data does it
make it an efficient use of the data
would I actually need ten times more
observations to achieve the same
accuracy to be able to answer these
questions well I need to define what the
curacy means and accuracy is something
that sort of makes sense it says well I
want theta hat to be close to theta and
but theta hat is a random variable so
I'm gonna have to understand what it
means for a random variable to be close
to a deterministic number and so what is
the parameter an estimator right so I
have an estimator and I said it's a
random variable and the formal
definition
so when estimator is a measurable
function of the data okay so when I
write theta hat and that will typically
be my notation for a an estimator right
I should really write feet a hat of X 1
X n okay that's what an estimator is if
you want to know what that estimator is
this is a measurable function of data
and it's actually also known as a
statistic and you know if you're
interested in you know I I see every day
I think what I have like you know a
dinner with normal people and yeah
really like baseball and they talk to me
about you know batting averages like
yeah that's not what I do
but for them that's what it is and
that's because in a way that's what it
statistic is the batting average is a
statistic okay and so here are some
examples you can take the average xn bar
you can take the maximum of your
observation that's the statistics you
can take the first one you can take the
first one plus log of 1 plus the
absolute value of the last one you can
do whatever you want that will be an
estimator some of them are clearly gonna
be bad but that still is just a stick
and you can do this now when I say
measurable I always have so you know
graduate students sometimes that's me
like how do I knew it's this estimator
is measurable or not and usually my
answer is well if I give you data can
you compute it and they say yeah I'm
like well then it's measurable that's a
very good rule to check if you can
actually if your something is actually
measurable when is this thing not
measurable is when it's implicitly
defined okay and in particular the
things that can give you problems are
[Music]
well yeah
soup or in it's like a Max or min but
that's not always attained okay so we
fates have x1 so if they look at the
infimum of the function f of X for X on
the real
and F of X sorry let's say X on one
infinity and f of X is equal to 1 over X
right then the infimum is the smallest
value it can take except that it does
not really take it it's zero right
because 1 over X is going to 0 but it's
never really getting there
so we just called the in zero but it's
not the value that it ever takes and
this thing might actually be complicated
to compute and so that's when you
actually have problems right when the
limit is not you're not really quite
reaching the limit you won't have this
problem in general but just so you know
that an estimator is not really anything
it has to actually be measurable ok so
the first thing we want to know I
mentioned it is so an an estimator is a
statistic which is not depend on theta
ok so if I give you the data you have to
be able to compute it and that probably
should not require and not knowing an
unknown parameter ok so an estimator is
said to be consistent if when my data
when I collect more and more data this
thing is getting closer and closer to
the true parameter all right and we said
that you know I bowling and saying that
it's gonna be for is not really
something that's probably gonna be
consistent but they can have things that
are consistent but that are converging
to theta at different speeds ok and we
know also that there's different this is
a random variable it converges to
something and we there might be some
different notions of conversions that
kick in and actually they are and we see
that it's weakly convergent if it
converges in probability and strongly
convergent if it converges almost surely
ok and this is just vocabulary and what
make a big difference ok so we will
typically say it's consistent what you
say any of this
well so in parametric statistics it's
actually a little difficult to come up
with but in nonparametric ones I could
just say if I have Y I X I Y I and I
know that Y is f of X I was some noise
f1 I I know that F belongs to some class
of functions would say so bullet class
of smooth functions massive all right
and now I'm gonna actually find the
following estimator I'm gonna take the
average so I'm gonna do least squares
right right so I just check I'm trying
to minimize the distance of each of my f
of X I to my Y I and now I want to find
the smallest of them okay so if I look
at the infimum here then the question is
so that could be well that's not really
an estimator for F so that's an
estimator for the smallest possible
value and so for example this is
actually an estimator for the variance
of Sigma square this might not be
attained in this way not me there may be
measurable all right so that's the info
for some class f of X ok so those are
always things that are defined
implicitly if it's an average for
example it's okay
any other question okay so we know that
the first thing we might want to check
and that's definitely something we want
about an estimator is that it's
consistent because all consistency tells
us is that yes as I could like more and
more data my estimator is going to get
closer and closer to the true parameter
there's other things we can look at for
each possible value of N now right now
I'm a have a have a finite number of
observation 25 and I want to know
something about my estimator the first
thing I want to check is maybe if in
average right so this is a random
variable is this random variable in
average gonna be close to theta or not
and so the difference how far I am from
theta is actually called the bias okay
so the bias of an estimator is the
expectation of theta hat minus the value
that I hope it gets which is Theta if
this thing is equal to 0 we say that
theta hat is unbiased and unbiased
estimators are things that people are
looking for in general the problem is
that there's lots of envious estimators
and so it might be misleading to look
for unbiasness when that's not really
the only thing you should be looking for
okay so what does it mean to be unbiased
maybe for this particular round of data
you collected you're actually pretty far
from the true estimator but one thing
that actually what it means is that if I
redid this experiment over and over and
over again and I a ver egde all the
values of my estimators that I got then
this would actually be the right the
truth grammar okay that's what it means
it's if I were to repeat this experiment
in average I would actually get the
right thing but you don't get to receive
it
okay just a remark about estimators look
at this estimator xn bar right think of
the kits example I'm looking at the
average of my observations and I want to
know what the expectation of this thing
is okay now this guy is by linearity
obviously expectation right but my data
is identically distributed so in
particular all the x i's have the same
expectation right everybody agrees with
this when it's identically distributed
they all get the same expectation so
what it means is that this guy's here
they're all equal to the expectation of
x1 right so what it means is that this
guy's I have the average of the same
number so this is actually the
expectation of x1 okay and it's true in
the kiss example this was P and this is
P the probability of turning your head
right okay so those two things are the
same in particular that means that xn
bar and just x1 have the same bias so
that should probably illustrate to you
that bias is not something that really
is telling you the entire picture right
I can take only one of my observations
Vernal easy row one this thing will have
the same bias as if I averaged a
thousand of them so the bias is really
telling me where I am in average but
it's really not telling me what's
actuations are getting and so if you
want to start having fluctuations coming
into the picture we actually have to
look at the risk or the quadratic risk
of an estimator and so the quadratic
risk is defined as the expectation of
the squared distance between theta hat
and theta okay
so that look let's look at this
so the traumatic rest sometimes it's you
noted that people call it the l2 risk of
state a hat of course I'm sorry for
maintaining such an ugly board ID for
winter this okay so I look at the
squared difference between theta hat sin
theta this is still the function of a
random variable so it's a random
variable as well and I'm looking at the
expectation of this guy okay that's the
definition I claim that when this thing
goes to 0 then my system a tourism
sistent everybody agrees with that
so if goes to zero as n goes to infinity
and here I don't need to tell you what
kind of convergence I have because this
is just the number rates that explain to
expectation so it's a regular usual
calculus style convergence then that
implies that theta hat is actually
weakly consistent what did I use to tell
you this
yeah this is the convergence in l2 but
this actually is strictly equivalent
this is by definition saying that theta
hat converges in l2
2 theta and we know that convergence in
l2 implies convergence in probability 2
theta right that with the picture we're
going up and this is actually equivalent
to we consistently by definition of okay
so this is actually telling me a little
more because this guy here they're both
unbiased data xn bar is an biased X 1
even by it
but X 1 is certainly not consistent
because the more data I collect I'm not
even doing anything with it I'm just
taking the first date of 1 you're giving
to me so they're both unbiased but this
one is not consistent and this one we'll
see is actually consistent xn bar is
consistent and actually we've seen that
last time and that's because of the what
guarantees the fact that xn bar is
consistent actually strongly consistent
to the strong ok
so just put in the last two minutes I
want to tell you a little bit about how
this risk is linked to see I said
quadratic risk is called to be a squared
plus variance let's see what I mean by
this so I'm gonna forget about the
absolute values that you have a square I
don't really need them if their hats
wasn't biased this thing would be the
expectation of theta hat right it might
not be the case so let me see how I can
actually see put the bias in there but
one way to do this is to say that this
is equal to the expectation of theta hat
minus expectation of theta hat plus
expectation of theta hat minus theta
okay I just removed the thing and added
the same thing so I didn't change
anything
now this guy is my bias right so now let
me expand the square so what I get is
the expectation of the square of theta
hat minus its expectation bracket plus
two times the cross product so the cross
product is what expectation of theta hat
minus expectation of theta hat times
expectation of theta hat minus theta
and then I have the last square
expectation of theta hat minus theta
squared okay so square cross products
square everybody's with me now this guy
here if you pay attention this thing is
the expectation of some random variable
so it's a deterministic number data is
the true parameter it's a deterministic
number so what I can do is pull out this
entire thing out of the expectation like
this
alright and compute the expectation only
with respect to that part but what is
the expectation of this thing it's zero
right expectation of theta hat minus
expectation of theta hat is zero so this
entire thing is equal to zero so now
when I actually collect back my
microbiotic terms my two squared terms
in this expansion what I get is that the
expectation of theta hat minus theta
squared is equal to the expectation of
theta hat minus expectation of theta hat
square
plus the square of expectation of theta
hat minus theta
right so those are just the two the
first and the last term of the previous
equality now here I have the expectation
of the square of the difference between
a random variable and its expectation
this is otherwise known as the variance
right so this is actually equal to the
variance of theta hat and this well this
was the bias we already said that's
there so this whole thing is the bias
squared okay and hence the static term
is the sum of the variance and the
squared bias Y squared bias well because
otherwise you would add dollars in
dollars squares squared right so you
need to add Dollar squared in dollars
for so that this thing is actually I'm a
genius okay so if X is in dollars then
the biases in dollars but the variances
in dollars work okay and the square here
forced you to put everything in this
world scale all right so what's nice is
that if the quadratic risk goes to zero
then since I have the sum of two
positive terms both of them have to go
to zero that means that my variance is
going to zero very little fluctuations
and my bias is also going to zero which
means that I'm actually going to be on
target
once I reduce my fluctuations because
it's one thing to reduce the
fluctuations but if I'm not on target
it's an issue right
for example the estimator for the value
4 has no variance every time I'm gonna
repeat the experiment I'm gonna get 4
for 4 for variance is 0 but the bias is
bad the bias is 4 minus theta and if
theta is falling apart from 4 that's not
doing very well ok so next week we will
all talk about what is a good estimate
what what how estimators change if they
have high variance or low variance so
our high bias and low bias and we'll
talk about confidence intervals as well
all right